hey what's up just welcoming various
yeah they go in me awesome fake that's
okay I'm sick toe yeah you're doing how
are you ma'am I'm saying yeah if I'm
happy and sick you look good sick though
thank you feel like again we're live by
the way the old okay this is our show
this is all I get this is what we do
we're just talking about Burt Reynolds
before and he's just keeps getting up to
have you have you met pearls at work to
them I have it no never met him never
met him you think that everybody in
Hollywood knows each other and you guys
if you know somebody that you had wanted
to meet that you just had we're never
able to oh yeah besides like this tough
question man how about Brando yeah
that's a good that's a good answer
Randle I've never met him are you out of
tune that my buddy oh yeah oh god yeah
sure we're good do you go do you go to
parties and events for movies it on
yours no you know there it really yeah
really
I might it's not something I usually do
do you like watching yourself sometimes
when I'm cooking you know it's okay but
when I'm not you know it's like was like
red light green light say I'm quite you
know critical you'll be on when the
movies good like the one that's out now
the only living boy in new york very
good
Midnight's always little in a Cell come
yeah yeah but when the movie is good to
forget myself and get sucked into the
story you don't yeah yeah and this is
one of those and I've told you before
what my favorite things you ever did was
the vanishing that was such a great
creepy role as Sandra Bullock was really
young but I think the original was
better do you ever dig the original I
did the French version or is it French
or one with your Dutch or so maybe yeah
but that that was I think was better
same director interesting Lin though why
do you think was better I thought you
you were better than the guy in it yeah
I don't think so man he was very good
but it's something for some reason
George slyzer the director wanted to
have the bad guy get his comeuppance you
know and so they killed killed me in the
American version and the other version
you know this guy I play is burying all
these people alive and the last
the movie is the guy is cabin and the
audience knows underneath his picnic
table are all these bodies they dig pass
the ketchup
yes wife and his kids you know much
mother dr. K yeah yeah Javan scary
ending the first one the French first TV
movies of yours that you'll watch like
multiple times like I'm just a fan of
the show I know Lebowski right back here
that you can't I can't stop that you
know watch when it comes on yeah yeah
you know you're not alone in that I
always say morpheme is so good I mean
yeah guys they do it so well you just
love that you just love that version of
yourself right I don't mind the version
myself but it's the movie you know those
guys are masters the broad the Coen
Brothers you know they just know how to
make it look so if like it's nothing it
is it difficult to work with like when
you've worked with Coen Brothers or
other amazing directors does it become
difficult when you get to a movie set
and you're dealing with a guy who's
obviously not on that level you know
what I mean like you probably know
pretty quick well is fascinating each
gig is so different you know it's like
plant yours like a poker card gave me
something like you play with different
people different game different hand
you've got you know I've had wonderful
luck with first-time directors you know
we haven't done much better than the
Citizen Kane you know and was e25 5.1 ya
know very you know it's nice yeah I
guess but they also have to probably
defer to you a lot to it maybe even if
you don't want them to because you're
Jeff Bridges so I knew a director must
be very nervous around you uh I don't
think I don't think so
does that put you in fear or I don't
know a fear is the right word but right
away when you sense a director is
intimidated by you or do you go like how
are we supposed to get anything done if
you're intimidated by me right know we'd
you know we Jam I mean it's a it's a
collaborative art form as so wow it's
kind of what you guys do here right let
me you know you're jamming right you're
just angry askin you want to guess I
want to feel relaxed right everybody
wants you no big deal your best work
comes out when you're relaxed so
everybody does their best to make the
other guy feel that way so we can get
some good work done we need to do
get up to speed pretty quick because we
have that much time to do it you
establish relationships on the set like
you end up being like really close
friends with people and then kind of
saying goodbye yeah they're like movies
are like little incarnations your little
lifetimes and you have a flip the
relationships go once it's done right
like you may see them again but that
relationship is just is now kind of come
to a close and maybe or maybe not it's
weird like I say it's uh like
incarnations you know like I like Pierce
Brosnan this is in this movie that's
coming out only living boy New York and
we worked on the mirror has two faces
another movie we've made here in New
York and it's like you know remember
that lifetime you know where you were
I'm always fascinated by that like I
don't know why but when I'm watching a
movie if two people are in the movie
that I knew did a movie together
previously and you're like hey they were
in that and for some reason I find that
fascinating I don't know why yeah well
it's interesting the whole thing of the
baggage that the audience brings with
them and you get yeah you can't but do
that and it really informs your
experience of the movie don't you think
yeah yeah I loved I loved your Rooster
Cogburn character and a True Grit and
there was some kind of scuttlebutt about
you doing the movie Rooster Cogburn now
I don't know who he was that any good
day I think it's pretty good you know
it's a really my sequel was it written
by Portis yes I wrote them yeah I think
so and it certainly did he did it oh he
did they did and the brothers are up for
it I'm there that would be Greg as a you
in a Western is pretty pretty good I
remember when the Coen brothers asked me
to be in in that movie and I thought
well why do you want to do that you know
I asked I said you know BEC John way it
is a big hit movie whities is well you
read the Charles Portis book I said no
he says we'll read the book and I read
the book and it's like a Coen Brothers
script is so perfect for them you know
wonderful book do you can you turn
something down like you'll actually
to be done if it's with somebody like if
you just don't think you're right for
yeah right or if it doesn't you know it
doesn't really ring my bell yeah have
you turned down things that you regret
it
no no your no regrets person or the
project run good or not right we're not
really not right yeah better was that
yeah big dude fifth correct right
yeah yeah there was some what years
something like that but I didn't regret
turning it down I'm going to I've got
but what you're just saying my guy with
no regret you guys I haven't that ik
what I sort of regret not spending more
time with my kids growing up you know
been you know making movies and oh ok
stuff you know fortunately my wife been
married 40 years Wow Wow
my wife did a great job and I can't did
the best I could I have a good
relationship with my girls now play
cat's in the cradle
you know you were away when they learned
well exactly the Harry Chapin to yeah
yeah hey so do you keep in close touch
to your brother yes very yeah he's one
of my favorite one of my favorite I love
Weaver talked about this but the
incident oh it was Martin first moving
bit cool yeah [ __ ] great Ed McMahon
Tony with something no oh yeah my
brother with that cash yeah yeah and
then I do that yeah when I shoot you you
are you went to the set of that yeah
yeah
what was that shot here in the your line
where I can't remember that was many
years ago
what a crazy movie they preside upon
their I just mad that you're Larry
Pierce right I thought I don't remember
I know Ruby Dee was in it and Brock
Peters yeah that was such an intense
scene yeah that was like the bad guys
are really like sad suit jackets on with
Martin Sheen and 20 Mossad the exact
time it was lasers time I gather yeah
when you work with like the Coen
brothers or directors they get along
with them
I wasn't evangelist that was just not
for you sir this question was not for
Jeff actually my fault um do you like
you know these filmmakers did work on
projects consistently like do you find
yourself going like hey Joel Ethan my
preaching of yeah you working on
anything I got anything for me I
probably would do you would write
I bet mine good the best yeah just just
to remind them of I guess over here you
know yeah think about everything about
this you know yeah did you ever want to
do Lebowski sequel sure I mean the
brothers are enduring there's always
rumors you know right you know - Turo
has got this movie coming out of you
guys heard about that but cha-cha jog
des terreaux is got a spinoff I guess
you'd call it of his Jesus character
from Lebowski and it should be absolute
he directed it and acted evidence Wow
yeah when you have to be in it no I
think it's like a it's like a retelling
of a French movie and like oh okay that
is but man do you like this movie the
last the only living boy in new york
which is in theaters Friday
lots of plot twists you're right it's
kind of hard to exactly explain the MOOC
is it in general yeah this is always
challenging for me how you you know get
this is like sort of the barker at the
carousel you know comedy movie you know
how you do that without ruining a sure
there's a movie that I want to see I
want to know as little about it as
possible don't you and even yeah there's
a lot of surprises now that give all
over that now if you don't want to
prepare you in a prime right right now
you're we have for the surprise
yeah that's wreck nothing is very
challenging man yeah I went to see the
big short it was a screening of it I had
no idea what it was about in vail movie
yeah I had zero idea so I went just
because I was invited to it and it was
real Paul McCartney was gonna be there
which he was not I just wanted to go and
I never would like to see a movie about
the financial crisis and I watched it
I'm like this is [ __ ] brilliant like
right I knew nothing about it it's the
best sometimes yeah when you go in there
I think the trailers give away much too
much oh it's terrible she that's that's
a big problem I think they should give
that job over to the director of the
movie cuz that's like brilliant rad a
prep you know that's like prep that's
like the first thing if anything but
they don't do that they give it to some
guys who it's their job to truncate the
whole story or tell all the you know yes
all the twists yeah although this move
and a trailer was on and they had me
within within like the first 10 seconds
I'm like I would see this dog and then I
had to just go out there not listen and
just wreck the whole thing you got me
you got me I mean they do they ruin them
do you think though it's partly because
if they want those guys are good at
making money the way they make trailers
like if the director did it wouldn't
make less money even though artistically
it'd be much closer to what a performers
one I don't know I mean I don't think so
i think the directors would do a better
job I really did it's tough though
because you want to sell them or you
want to say like look at all the clothes
up in here but you don't want to give
away the storylines and all the
surprises you think about like what was
um when I'm trending what's the what was
the one what was the movie ahead of like
a big egg it was kind of cracking and
that was all it Mork from ork alien that
was you know gonna be happy without a
easy yeah what is that you know just
write about titillation man that's all
it was
yeah yeah just little thing one graphic
and some yeah meeting like that and say
yeah I I can't tell you how many times
like we end up watching movies tell them
in advance because guys are coming in to
promote or whatever that is and like so
I'll watch a movie with no knowledge of
what it is and I'll be like oh that was
greater this part of that part and then
I'll turn a trailer on and I'll be like
this moment that I just had because I
watched our trailer is gone yeah yeah
bendito if I had seen the trailer it
really and had gotten longer and longer
they used to be pretty yes and a lot of
times like they would just kind of Ember
the trailer from magic with Anthony
Hopkins like you just knew how about a
creepy magician well I'm an older man
but uh you you knew very little about it
and they they just they tell you too
much I'm like rolling with old 70s
trailers where it's like making county
line or something like that or you know
the movie um Bob Rafelson you know Bob
Rafelson is you know directed five Easy
Pieces
okay famous director the Monkees that
was his creation and he did a movie
called head did you see that movie now I
love the starkness the wives you know
the monkeys were in it was the monkey
movie conovan you had your Victor Mature
ahead you know the exact weird just it's
a weird movie it's weird yeah acting out
I'm surprised
it's not you know had a rethink but at
the end of it it was you've just
received three minutes of head that was
the Coen brothers now what they wanted
for the trailer to be a Lebowski
remember when flea
you know flea was in the movie you know
the bass player might be he's in he's
one of the bad guys you know and he gets
hit in the balls with the bowling ball
or something he's got I just need a rise
on the ground and that take that we shot
he drives on the ground for three
minutes
yeah it'd be curious that's funny yeah
CEO said no I guess maybe they exist
somewhere right that's the only trailer
available for the best the trying almost
a few people have such short attention
span like mine has gotten shorter I
think they're just trying for quick like
pow-pow-pow just fast moment nothing
unfold it special sellers because that's
a do people lose interest the I want to
ask you about your dad of course you
know Lloyd Bridges yeah just first of
all the early days just a real leading
man good looks guy and then later in his
career just a funny guy and that sense
of humor there were a couple of actors
that had this weird transition into the
comedy genre after being serious actor
there and only a couple of them really
pulled it off well and your dad was one
of those yeah I well you know it's
interesting we were talking about the
you know baggage and personas that
actors you develop and in the late 60s
he had that sehun sehun sehun control
emotion and people thought this is a big
compliment that he was a skin diver
yeah well that part up so well no that's
what the guy it he got a lot of skin
diving offers you know to play these
movies you know and that was tough for
him because he was a Shakespearean actor
comedian all these different things but
he kept getting that part than that
one reason why I tried to kind of mix up
and not develop like for strong for so
people could imagine me in the character
there was it did a movie years ago
called blown away and I was talking to
the producers I say you know who could
play my uncle in this movie great actor
looks a little bit like me miss Lloyd
Bridges is hot and the guy laughs he
says yeah your dad is a wonderful actor
but he's really more of a comedian Wow
what are you talking Wow man he says
yeah well you know airplane were the USA
you're gonna make the guy come in and
read and they write
he said woody I said yeah kidding me so
we came to knocks it out of the park you
know yeah how did you ask him to do you
have to ask him to read or do they ask
him I uh I can't run I probably asked
him I'm you know asking Lloyd Bridges
the communal audition that's like a yeah
was there ever any and any jealousy or
weirdness and the family with so many
actors because I mean that movie is like
the kids are a writer the dad's a writer
and there's weird yeah supportive of no
it's really kind of uh my dad won all of
us to go into showbiz he yes oh wow oh
man you know and for me it was tough
because who wants to do what their
parents want us to do yeah yeah I said
no I don't know I'm into music painting
art and stuff he says it'll be
ridiculous you're going to get to do all
of that you know that's the cool thing
about acting's you get to draw on all
your interests and stuff and then but no
there was anything with bow no bows my
in a teacher we're always rooting for
each other you know doing the Baker boys
was like a dream come true yeah great to
play with each other when you did that
King Kong I love that the 77 I think
that was when you guys did King Kong
that I was always terrified that scene
in the trade center where you're
standing outside like it looks like
you're holding on to the two pieces of
metal oh yeah where do they shoot that
attention oh man come on where'd you
shoot that I like I'm dying I know that
you didn't shoot it there but where was
it what do you mean we
we know we didn't shoot wait when you
were standing outside oh I can not share
view I remember your shot but we
certainly shot it at the Trade Center we
you you were around New York Dan I was
in Jersey I was another boy so we're
shooting that we just come to the Trade
Towers you weren't there and then and
this little guy comes up to me and says
would be like my tempo I see your tempos
it is my tempo I say you're a little bit
there this is my tempo say what do you
mean he says I walked across awfully
high it was the year Philippe Petit Wow
and he says a do juggle do we like toys
I would teach you and he taught me about
five minutes out of juggle and I let it
remain what an honor
laughs did you find out he was a little
needy when he came and said I said do
you remember me from up there I was just
a walk but I need to just walk across
did 90 minutes he did a bunch of back
ties back and forth yeah and then he was
far his punishment for doing that was to
entertain for free in Central Park huh
that was his thing do you how much he
had to pay a fine what was financially
it was a dollar ten years like a penny
for every floor really yeah that was a
fine they gave him a break walking
around New York and you'd see you
looking someone is that what it is
there's a guy on a unicycle holding onto
a taxicab coming his way and he would
come in he'd have a big rope on his
shoulder and he'd get a bunch of strong
guy he wouldn't say anything I was just
you know the mind kind of deal and he
tied this one end of the rope to a tree
or something had these strong guys pull
it and he would leap up on the rope and
do a thing people would gather around
and he jump off take the rope off get
all the people in a long line facing
each other two lines facing as he get
one end and he would time it perfectly
on his unicycle take his head off just
to do and he'd catch a cab I'll be to go
after anything I know so was there any
time when you were students no time when
you were shooting whether it was like a
window of the Trade Center open were you
on the outside of it right
how would you forget that that's
horrifying I remember Google Jeff
Bridges encontre Senate man because I
Drive that scene [ __ ] horrified me so
much usually you were watching the
gorilla on the other building and I
think you were like outside of the
chicken huh I remember I remember
pitching Dino De Laurentiis in the
director John Gill Erma I had this flash
I so you know how the movie should in
monkey should fall down crash on the
ground catch on fire Oh and turn out to
be a giant machine oh man end of a good
setup for the next Wow my Charles Grodin
character buys the carcass that's the
ticket around then the aliens come I
might hit a hole yes no I I did a tune
written about that story and my buddy
burgess Meredith we hung out a lot at
that time and he had a whole speaking
part in the middle of this tune based on
the Hindenburg day you know oh my god
all do you man and he is falling in the
monkeys on fire he did that yeah and
have dead Dino and just looked at me
like well thank you Greg yes Chevy Chevy
coma - Jeffy I'd like to know burgess
Meredith I'm a big of mice and man
Island man oh yeah Burgess what a great
guy we eat after last picture show my
next movie was a movie called the yin
and yang of mr. go James Mason played a
Chinese Mexican and the movie Wow
yeah they used to do that yeah we shot
we shot for months and in Hong Kong and
just have a very a great time ink on ya
then haha yeah I'm gonna fun career on
and ding dong that's it they tell us we
have to wrap up with yeah I can talk to
you all day you're uh yeah I'm so great
everything I've never seen you in
anything I didn't like you and like you
just you want to write favorite actors
you're incredible so and it's always
different
there's never anything like oh there's
Jeff right there's always some [ __ ]
crazy person you play a great psychopath
ha ha you do now I'm Barney whoa